.
Ein Luzerner Unternehmer
kämpft um seine Firma.
Wir möchten sie nicht entlassen,
wir möchten nur arbeiten.
Corona bringt das Unternehmen
zum Stillstand.
Es tut weh, es tut mir selber weh.
Eine Künstlerin muss alles absagen.
Dann ist es so,
dass ich momentan keinen Lohn habe.
Corona gefährdet ihre Existenz.
Ich bin froh um den Sozialstaat
und will ihn nicht aushöhlen.
Zwei Luzerner Freunde führen
in der Touristenstadt ein Hotel.
Sie geben alles,
um das Haus zu retten.
Es macht einen traurig,
wenn so wenig Leute kommen.
Jetzt gibt es
wirklich nur noch Vollgas, vorwärts.
Ihre Geschichten in:
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Luzern im Corona-Shutdown.
Wo sich sonst
Einheimische und Touristen drängeln -
nichts als Leere.
Sechs lange Wochen.
Dann, nach der ersten Welle,
im Mai 2020,
erwacht die Stadt
zu neuem Leben.
Im Hotel Beau Séjour,
mitten in Luzern,
wird mit Elan und Optimismus
die Wiedereröffnung vorbereitet.
Der Start in eine Zukunft,
von der niemand genau weiss,
was sie bringen wird.
Hoteldirektor Manuel Berger
und sein Geschäftspartner sind froh,
endlich wieder loslegen zu können.
Doch der zurückgewonnenen Freiheit
trauen noch nicht alle so ganz.
Grüezi.
Ja, genau.
Verbleiben wir so.
Ich streiche das Datum und Sie
können sich jederzeit melden.
Super. Gut. Schönen Tag,
Frau Fischer. Auf Wiederhören.
So, nun habe ich
die Buchung gelöscht.
Das ist ein 70. Geburtstag
mit 50-55 Leuten.
Es gab in den letzten zwei Monaten
enorm viele Absagen.
Es kamen täglich
mehr Stornierungen als Buchungen,
d.h. Buchungen gab es in den
letzten zwei Monaten gar keine.
Ja, das tut schon
ein wenig weh, wenn man merkt,
dass ganz viel Umsatz
im Jahr 2020 wegbricht,
und man nicht so genau weiss,
wie es weitergeht.
Unverhofft
findet sich der junge Hoteldirektor
in der grössten Krise
unserer Zeit wieder.
Damit hat er nicht gerechnet,
als er vor zweieinhalb Jahren
das Beau Séjour
als Pächter übernommen hat.
Der Shutdown sitzt auch
seinem Geschäftspartner Walter
"Willy" Willimann in den Knochen.
Schockzustand,
dann Wut, dann Trauer,
dann langsam akzeptieren
und irgendwann ...
... so ...
... so am Tiefpunkt sagen:
"Jetzt geht es nur vorwärts."
Es gibt keine Alternative.
Wenn wir als Unternehmer
nicht positiv sind,
dann sind es
unsere Mitarbeiter auch nicht.
Schlussendlich sinkt die Stimmung,
und dann schafft man es nicht.
Hast du frische Socken an?
- Nein, natürlich nicht.
Auch nicht desinfiziert.
Es ist alles eine Katastrophe.
Es ist
einfach alles eine Katastrophe.
Im historischen Hotel
soll das Alte erhalten
und mit Neuem verbunden werden.
Daran arbeiten Walter Willimann
und die Gast-Künstlerin Nina Stähli.
* Leichter Knall *
Was ist kaputt?
Schlagzeile:
"Hotelgast erschlagen von Ölbild."
Ich finde es eigentlich schön.
Schaust du aus der Entfernung?
Ich habe einen schiefen Blick.
Vielleicht rechts etwas höher.
Rechts höher?
- Ja.
Mit kreativen Ideen
wollen Manuel und Willy
das Sommergeschäft ankurbeln.
Um Corona-bedingte Einbussen
bei den Übernachtungen wettzumachen,
soll ein Kiosk
Flaneure vom See anlocken.
Okay.
Im ländlichen Willisau,
30 km von Luzern entfernt,
ist der grösste Festzeltbauer
der Schweiz zu Hause.
Doch wo keine Events stattfinden,
braucht es auch keine Festzelte.
Nach dem Shutdown
herrscht bei Roland Küng,
dem CEO der Firma Hunziker,
Krisenstimmung.
Ein Morgen, wieder einmal mehr
ein ruhiger Morgen,
an dem im Prinzip nichts läuft.
Um diese Jahreszeit müsste hier
eigentlich alles leer sein.
Jetzt gäbe es viele Grossanlässe.
Die gibt es jetzt nicht.
Dementsprechend komme ich
morgens alleine ins Büro.
Ich weiss, dass noch keine
Bauarbeiter auf der Baustelle sind.
Jetzt schaue ich wieder,
was an Absagen gekommen ist,
wie es weitergeht und ...
In normalen Zeiten
würden seine 70 Angestellten
jetzt in der ganzen Schweiz
Festzelte aufbauen,
die Lagerhallen wären leer.
Gesamthaft
haben wir rund 8'000 Stühle.
Das ist die Tribünenbestuhlung.
Es steht keine einzige Tribüne,
kein Sportanlass - nichts.
Alle ist daheim.
Eigentlich müsste es
auch hier so weit leer sein.
Alle Blachen.
Ca. 200'000 m2 Blachen, mit denen
man eine Festhalle decken könnte.
Es ist praktisch alles hier.
Es kommt mir manchmal vor
wie im Märchen, in "Dornröschen".
Da schlafen doch alle ein,
alles bleibt liegen.
Der Hammer liegt da,
wo er zuletzt gebraucht wurde.
Einzig die Leute
gingen bei uns nach Hause.
Der Rest ist manchmal wie am Tag X,
als wir aufhörten und sagten:
"Geht alle nach Hause,
geht in die Kurzarbeit."
So liegt alles noch hier.
Dabei war alles vorbereitet
für ein Jahr voller Events.
Bodenmaterial, Bodenmaterial,
X-tausend Quadratmeter.
Investiert, gekauft für die Saison,
für alle Aufträge
haben wir neues Material gekauft.
Nie gebraucht.
In Luzerns Peripherie,
in Emmenbrücke,
am meist befahrenen Platz der Stadt,
steht die älteste Showbude
der Schweiz.
Das Varieté-Theater
ist über 70 Jahre alt.
Claudia Kienzler
hat den Verein gegründet,
der das Varieté gekauft hat.
Und hat damit
ein riskantes Projekt übernommen.
Nach der Renovation soll hier
das Publikum Akrobatik, Musiktheater
und Kulinarik geniessen können.
Claudia hätte 1'000 gute Ideen,
wenn sie denn loslegen könnten.
Was jetzt noch eine Baustelle ist,
wird dann der Spielort werden.
Hier oben wird ein Trapez
für die ganze Luftartistik hängen.
Das ist die sog. Showtreppe.
Das ist ein beliebter Ort
mit der besten Aussicht.
Es hat viele Klappen,
wo man verschwinden
und irgendwo wieder auftauchen kann.
Die anderen sind blockiert.
Hier kommt man dann wieder hoch.
Das gleiche Spiel links und rechts.
Es sind etwa 60 Gäste,
die Platz haben.
Es ist unvorstellbar, aber es geht,
falls das nächstes Jahr möglich ist.
Zum jetzigen Corona-Stand
wäre das nicht möglich.
Wenn wir hier die Abstände einhalten
müssen, wird es sehr schwierig.
Das ist die Planungsunsicherheit,
mit der ich umgehen muss.
Ich muss schauen,
wie es sich entwickelt,
wie es ist, wenn die Leute aus
den Sommerferien nach Hause kommen -
wie es mit dem Virus
und der Pandemie steht.
Claudia hofft, dass sich
die Situation bis im Herbst 2020
etwas normalisieren wird
und sich die Pandemie
als kurzer Schrecken erweist.
Bei der Renovation packt
die Künstlerin an, wo wie kann.
Ich helfe selbstverständlich
bei der Planung mit.
Streichen, denn das müssen die
Zimmermänner nicht unbedingt machen.
So können wir Geld und Zeit sparen.
Wenn ich
oder Freiwillige das machen.
Bei Sämtlichem anpacken eben.
Die 39-Jährige
leitet ein dreiköpfiges Team,
welches das Varieté
wieder auf Vordermann bringt.
Die Kleber sind doch
immer oben an einer Schraube?
Ja, da hat es Eisen dahinter.
Das Eisen ist darunter,
das spürt man nicht.
Man kann Kabel treffen.
- Das machen wir nicht.
Ich bin einfach Zimmermann.
Zimmermann und Zeltmeister.
Genau, Zeltmeister vom Varieté.
Er kennt jede Schraube.
- Ja, es hat ziemlich viele.
Es gibt solche,
die nicht so gut sind,
aber die meisten kenne ich.
Es ist eine komplexe Logistik
vom Aufbau her.
Nicht rot werden.
- Ja, ja.* Beide lachen. *
Fertig.
- Ja, fertig.
Das Varieté
tingelte über 70 Jahre durchs Land.
Auch Claudia
war für ein paar Saisons mit dabei.
Mit der Übernahme
hat sie die marode Bude
vor dem Abbruch gerettet.
Für mich macht es den Charme aus.
Das Alter ist es,
was es für viele ausmacht.
Dass es teils
auch unlogisch gebaut
oder relativ komplex im Aufbau ist.
Es wurde
mit alten Materialien gearbeitet.
Dasgibt den Charakter
und das Flair, die dazugehören,
wenn man mit Wagen unterwegs ist,
mit alten Wagen, mit Traktoren.
Ihre drei Angestellten
bekommen einen Lohn,
sich selber kann sie den
aber vorerst nicht auszahlen.
Ich konnte meine Fixkosten im Leben
relativ tief halten,
also z.B. die Mietkosten.
Ich habe kein eigenes Auto,
sondern teile eines.
Ich brauche auch nicht sehr viel.
Mich macht es freier,
mit wenig zu leben als mit viel.
Auch die Hoteliers des Beau Séjour
erwirtschaften derzeit
kein Einkommen.
Dafür müssen sie in den 28 Zimmern
erst wieder Gäste haben.
Das ist genau das blöde ...
- Ich hasse Schränke.
Ganz in die Ecke geht es nicht,
aber in etwa so.
So ist es viel besser.
- In der Ecke ist es wirklich ...
Ich finde es in der Ecke hässlich.
- Das finde ich auch.
20 cm sind gut.
Es ist ein super cooler Schrank.
Mir verbringen viel Zeit
mit den Details,
aber wir glauben,
dass die Hotellerie ...
Es gibt so viele Sachen, die zum
Running Gag der Mitarbeiter wurden.
"Ja, Manuel, das sieht ja niemand."
"Das sieht ja kein Gast."
Zur Antwort gebe ich jeweils:
"Ja, aber ich sehe es."
Wenn etwas nicht gut ist,
ist das schade.
Das ist eben der Groove des Hotels,
dass wir so arbeiten wollen.
Willy und Manuel
haben grosse Visionen.
Manuel hat auch
das Alltagsgeschäft im Auge.
Wollen wir nicht noch etwas weniger?
- Wo haben wir die tieferen?
Ich würde die nehmen. Ich finde
die von der Grösse her super.
Wie viel füllst du ab?
Ich stelle noch Schälchen daneben,
dann können sie noch mehr nehmen.
Das ist gut.
Das Reinigungspersonal muss sich
mit neuen Corona-konformen
Hygienemassnahmen vertraut machen.
Also es geht eigentlich
um die ... ähm ...
... Griffe, Fenster, Türen,
Schränke,
Dosen, Lichtschalter, Dosen auch.
Der Affe kommt raus.
Hotelmaskottchen Maimu
wird Opfer der Hygienemassnahmen.
Der Kuschelaffe
soll keine Viren weitergeben können.
Wir haben unsere schönen Maimus
in den Zimmern.
Über sie wurde bei uns im Geschäft
kontrovers diskutiert.
Wir haben uns nun entschieden,
sie für den Moment
aus den Zimmern zu nehmen.
Willy wusste das noch nicht.
Das ist jetzt eine shocking news.
Das sind so Sachen,
die wir operativ entscheiden.
Vielleicht
setzen wir sie irgendwo ...
... hin.
Manuel träumte mal davon,
Architekt zu werden -
geblieben
ist seine Liebe zum Detail.
Der Stift ist nicht nett mit mir.
Vielleicht wird die zweite Tafel
schon viel, viel schöner.
Das glaube ich eben nicht.
Ich bin überhaupt nicht zufrieden
mit dem "Snacks",
das ich geschrieben habe.
Aber es wird
niemand keine Snacks kaufen,
weil die Schrift nicht so schön ist.
Daran wird es nicht scheitern.
Wenn ich irgendwann mehr Zeit habe,
werde ich es noch einmal schreiben.
Manu macht es so lange,
bis es ihm gefällt,
und wenn er es
100-mal schreiben muss.
Wenn ich das GELATERIA DELL' ALPI
anschaue - das wird immer grösser.
Die Terrasse mit dem Kiosk
und das Hotel sind bereit,
morgen ist Eröffnung.
Von einem Neustart ist man bei der
Zeltbaufirma Hunziker weit entfernt.
Seit vier Monaten
läuft hier fast nichts mehr.
Das KMU hat vor der Pandemie stets
die grössten Events ausgerichtet.
Jetzt ist CEO Roland Küng
froh um jeden kleinen Auftrag,
sei es für eine Hochzeit
oder den Samariterverein.
Hallo, Franz.
- Hallo, Roland.
Was machst du?
Glaubenberg, das Blutspenden.
Das ist das einzige,
das wir nächste Woche haben.
Welche Zeltgrösse
brauchen wir dafür?
Einmal 12 m Zehner
und einmal 15 m Zehner.
Zwölf auf zehn, 15 auf zehn.- Und
einmal sind es sechs mal sechs.
Drei kleine Zelte,
das ist das ganze Volumen
für die nächste Woche.
Ich habe daheim noch
mit dem Umbau des Hauses zu tun.
Etwas malen, etwas renovieren.
Meine Frau geht etwas mehr arbeiten.
Dann spiele ich daheim
ein wenig Hausmann.
Das ist eine Abwechslung,
etwas anderes.
Es ist schon schwierig,
manchmal sind die Tage lang.
Auch moralisch
ist es nicht immer gleich,
weil ich es gewohnt bin,
immer zur Arbeit zu gehen.
V.a. jetzt in der Hauptsaison
ist es schlimm.
Nachher hast du Feierabend?
- Ja.
Freitag um 10 Uhr!
- Bei diesem schlechten Wetter.
Franz, danke. Ein schönes
Wochenende.- Danke, gleichfalls.
Kurz vor dem Shutdown
investierte das Unternehmen
in eine neue Waschanlage
für Zeltblachen.
Eine Viertelmillion
hat sie gekostet,
jetzt ist sie nur selten im Einsatz.
Wir bieten die Leute auf,
so haben alle die Möglichkeit,
zwischendurch etwas zu arbeiten.
Sie machen dann Arbeiten,
die sie sonst nicht machen,
Arbeiten aus anderen Abteilungen.
Aber ich glaube -
das wirst du sicher bestätigen -
hat praktisch noch keiner gesagt,
dass er nicht käme.
Wenn ich anrufe, heisst es:
"Ja, ich komme."
Das ist eben schön.
Es ist schön, wenn man
zwischendurch etwas arbeiten kann,
irgendetwas machen kann.
Im Sommer des letzten Jahres
mussten wir von 120 % auf 20 %
oder 10 % runterfahren.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Die Mitarbeiter sollen beschäftigt
werden, auch auf lange Sicht.
Entlassungen sind bei Hunziker
derzeit kein Thema.
Claudia Kienzler ist
ausgebildete klassische Musikerin.
Vor der Corona-Krise ist sie
in verschiedenen Formationen
mit klassischer und
zeitgenössischer Musik aufgetreten.
Im Luzerner KKL,
in Berlin oder Tokio.
* Sanfte Geigenmusik *
Die Geige
ist meine treuste Begleiterin.
Sie begleitet mich
oder gehört zu mir,
seit ich
vier oder fünf Jahre alt bin.
Es ist auch eine gewisse Sanftheit,
die in mir ist,
aber auch eine gewisse Sturheit,
die in mir ist.
Ich habe mir das jetzt in den Kopf
gesetzt, und dann will ich das.
Ich bleibe ihr treu
oder sie bleibt mir treu.
Sie musste etwas warten,
bis ich wieder zu ihr kam,
aber ich kam immer wieder
zu ihr zurück.
Nun müssen Claudia und ihre Geige
gemeinsam warten,
denn im Frühsommer
ist kein einziger Auftritt in Sicht.
In normalen Zeiten
flanieren Heerscharen von Touristen
durch Luzern.
Jetzt herrscht selbst
vor dem Löwendenkmal gähnende Leere.
Gleich daneben findet sich
eine Filiale von Casagrande,
dem grössten
Souvenir-Händler Luzerns.
Robert Casagrande besitzt zusammen
mit seinem Bruder fünf Filialen,
die aktuell
jedoch kaum Kundschaft haben.
Es hat schon Touristen, die kommen.
Das Geschäft mit den Reisenden
liegt ihm im Blut
und hat seine Familie
wohlhabend gemacht.
Jetzt, vor den Sommerferien,
hofft er doch noch auf viele Gäste.
Das ist einer der ersten Busse,
der in Luzern ankommt.
Wahrscheinlich
kommt er irgendwo aus Europa.
Vermutlich eine Tagesreise,
die sie hierher führt.
Dasfreut mich natürlich sehr.
Hier am Grendel war vor der Pandemie
kein Durchkommen mehr.
Zum grossen Ärger der Einheimischen.
Doch ein Casagrande
stört sich nicht am Overtourism.
Normalerweise stehen hier drei Cars.
Möglicherweise hat es noch andere
Cars, die vor der Ankunft stehen.
Sie haben 3 Min. Zeit,
um die Leute aussteigen zu lassen.
Nachher sammeln sie sie an einem Ort
und verteilen sie
in die verschiedenen Geschäfte.
In dieser Gasse stehen sie meistens
pyramidenförmig in einer Gruppe.
Mit dabei ist ein Boss,
der relativ viel Geld hat
und bei Bucherer
eine Rolex oder eine Piaget
und bei Gübelin
eine Patek Philippe kauft.
Die anderen Leute, die weniger Geld
haben, kommen zu uns.
Hier kaufen sie die normalen
Souvenirs - Uhren, Schokolade usw.
Die Bosse kommen, nachdem sie für
sich etwas gekauft haben, zu uns.
Aber wegen Corona
läuft am Grendel gar nichts.
Der Ur-Luzerner Casagrande
kennt die ganze Stadt.
Auf dem Samstagsmarkt,
der jetzt wieder möglich ist,
trifft man sich wie vor dem Shutdown.
Keine Personenbeschränkungen,
keine Maskenpflicht.
Ich habe dich in Facebook gesehen.
Hast du etwas Arbeit?
Im Moment weiss man gar nichts,
aber ich plane im Oktober.
Inshallah.
- Aha, Inshallah.
Ich schreibe dir in zwei Wochen,
wenn du Zeit hast.
Tschau.
- Tschau.
Das ist eine liebe Freundin,
die in Dubai lebt.
Und wenn wir in Dubai waren, hat sie
uns jeweils das Hotel organisiert.
Sie ist eine Luzernerin.
Sie hat im Golfklub,
wo ich spiele, gearbeitet.
Selbst dem Gemüsehändler
fehlen die Touristen.
Es gab noch Zeiten, in denen es
hiess: "Ach, die vielen Touristen."
Ich glaube, jetzt merkt jeder,
dass es weniger sind.
Ich spüre es am meisten.
Ja, du und die Uhrenhändler
und auch die Hotels.
Es hat zwar viele Schweizer,
die hier Ferien machen,
aber sie fehlen trotzdem.
Robert Casagrande
ist ein Luzerner Original.
Du nimmst natürlich nicht immer ab.
Das weiss ich,
du als heimlicher Stadtpräsident.
Schönes Wochenende.
- Okay, tschau, Max.
Das kann man so sagen.
Ich war über 30 Jahre
Vorstandspräsident
des Quartiervereins Altstadt.
Von daher kenne ich alle Leute.
Ich bin extrem vernetzt.
Hoi zusammen, hoi Esthi.
Margito, alles klar?
Wunderbar.
Ich komme nachher zu dir.
Der 66-Jährige pflegt einen lockeren
Umgang, auch beim Händeschütteln.
Vielleicht auch beeinflusst durch
die derzeit tiefen Neuansteckungen
von nur gerade 26 schweizweit.
* Akzentuierte Klänge *
* Gemächliche Musik *
Im Mai 2020 treffen
im Luzerner Hotel Beau Séjour
die ersten Gäste
nach dem Shutdown ein.
Nach langen Wochen zu Hause
können sie endlich wieder reisen
und Vermisstes nachholen.
Das ist so klein geschrieben.
Name und Geburtstatum?- Ja, genau.
Wir wären über Auffahrt in einem
Yoga-Retreat in Österreich gewesen,
nahe der Grenze.
Weil wir
nicht über die Grenze konnten,
entschlossen wir uns
in der Schweiz etwas zu entdecken.
Und Luzern ist wunderbar.
Es ist im dritten Stock,
gleich vis-à-vis vom Lift.
Frühstück gibt es im Ballsaal.
Wenn Sie etwas trinken wollen,
ist draussen unser Sommerkiosk.
Schönen Aufenthalt, danke.
- Danke.
Die Hotelgäste
Fabienne Märki und ihr Mann
haben etwas Wichtiges zu feiern.
Herzlich willkommen bei uns
und einen schönen Aufenthalt.
Ade, miteinander.
Megaschön.
Wir haben
vor zwei Wochen geheiratet.
Weil wir nun nicht
in die Flitterwochen können,
verreisen wir nun eben
übers Wochenende.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Der Betrieb läuft und der 35-jährige
Hoteldirektor blüht auf
in seiner Rolle als Gastgeber.
Das ist ein sehr schönes Gefühl.
Dafür betreiben wir ein Hotel:
damit auch Gäste kommen.
Normalerweise
kommen sie aus der ganzen Welt,
aber jetzt v.a. aus der Schweiz.
Das freut uns sehr.
Dieses Gefühl
hatten unsere Mitarbeiter auch.
Im Lockdown
wurde es manchmal etwas Lethargisch.
Doch die letzten drei Tage
habe ich gemerkt,
dass sich alle
über die Gäste freuen.
Das ist ein schönes Gefühl.
Manuel verlässt sich
auf seine drei Mitarbeitenden,
die er unbedingt
im Hotel behalten will.
Wir haben Kurzarbeit angemeldet,
weil die Mitarbeiter
nicht arbeiten konnten.
Aber wir haben keine Leute entlas-
sen, das haben wir auch nicht vor.
Ich glaube, das ist
das oberste Ziel in dieser Zeit,
dass wir keine Leute
aus unserem Hotel entlassen müssen.
Gut,
bis jetzt funktioniert das super.
Unsere Gäste draussen sind happy.
Die meisten Hotelgäste
stammen aus der Schweiz.
Ausländische Touristen sind selten.
Dem Beau Séjour
gelingt es aber auch,
Passanten von der Seepromenade
in den neu eingerichteten Sommerkiosk
zu locken.
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Manuel hilft aus,
wo es ihn gerade braucht.
Bar, Küche, Reception -
Hauptsache nah bei den Gästen.
Je mehr Menschen es sich
im Beau Séjour gemütlich machen,
umso gelassener wirkt der Hotelier.
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Nur im Backoffice
gibt es ein kleines Drama.
Der zieht zu viel Strom ab.
Ein Kurzschluss.
Jede Veränderung
bei der Infrastruktur ...
Unser Sandwichgrill
zieht zu viel Strom ab.
Jetzt ist
die Sicherung rausgeflogen.
Die Sicherung?
- Ja, draussen geht das noch nicht.
Aber zusammen
meistern sie das Malheur.
Und das Fazit des Tages
fällt positiv aus.
Ich bin sehr glücklich,
dass sehr viele Hotelgäste kommen.
Heute haben wir
nur noch ein Zimmer frei.
Morgen, nach den Auffahrtstagen,
reisen wieder ein paar ab.
Wir haben aber bis Sonntag
noch viele Leute im Haus.
Es sind auch viele bekannte
Gesichter aus Luzern hier.
Die kamen oft zu uns
und kommen auch jetzt wieder.
Ich bin recht zuversichtlich. Ich
freue mich auf die kommende Zeit.
Ich glaube daran, dass wir
im Hotel Gäste haben werden.
Wir können einfach
noch nicht genau sagen wie viele.
Wenn es
eine Konstante gibt im Coronajahr,
dann ist es seine Unplanbarkeit.
Von einem Aufschwung ist
bei der Firma Hunziker in Willisau
nichts zu spüren.
Seit dem Shutdown plant kein
Veranstalter einen grossen Event.
Zu unsicher, zu viel Risiko.
Wir haben heute den 19. Juni.
Und seit dem 28. Februar läuft das
eigentlich mehr oder weniger so.
Das ist eine extrem lange Zeit.
Es gibt Aufs und Abs.
Mittlerweile ist eigentlich unser
komplettes Jahr, sage ich einmal,
mittlerweile abgesagt.
Ein paar wenige wurden auf nächstes
Jahr verschoben, die orangefarbenen.
Alles, was rot ist, ist abgesagt.
Ich kann es kurz aufzählen.
Bern BEA: Im April war die GV-Saison
der Banken und Grossfirmen,
bei denen wir sehr viel machen.
Alles wurde abgesagt.
Schwingfeste, die abgesagt wurden,
die Eishockey-WM, Truckerfestival,
Greenfield-Festival.
Grob gesagt sehen wir hier, dass
90 % des Jahresumsatzes wegfällt.
Dieses Jahr ist vorbei.
Ja.
Noch nie hat das 85-jährige Unter-
nehmen so schwierige Zeiten erlebt.
Nur vereinzelt gibt es für den Zelt-
bauer kleinere Aufträge auszuführen.
Met, hoi.
Geht's gut?
- Ja.
Es geht tipptopp.
Avdi, hoi.
- Hoi.
Wie läuft's?- Gut.- Schön,
wieder einmal zu arbeiten?- Ja.
In 35 Jahren
ist so etwas noch nie passiert.
Aber ich ...
- Wie lange bist du dabei?
Am 1. Februar waren es 35 Jahre.
Und du Met?
- 30 Jahre.
30 Jahre.
Ich habe 1985 angefangen.
Damals war ich Student.
Es sieht die nächsten paar Wochen
schlecht aus.
Ich habe es gehört.
Meine Hoffnung ist
das Herbstgeschäft, Spätherbst,
sicher Winter wieder.
Das ist eine kurze Sache - 2 Std.
Aber im Endeffekt besser als nichts.
So kleine?
Nur grosse, grosse, grosse.
Wie viele hatten wir?
200'000, 100'000 Leute.
30'000, 35'000, 70'000 Leute -
das ist viel.
Für dieses Zelt
sind es wie viele Leute?
Das ist für eine Hochzeit.
Das sind ca. 150 Leute.
Das ist für Hunziker nichts.
Besser wenig als absolut nichts.
* Akzentuierte Klänge *
Mit dem Kauf des Varietés
ist Musikerin Claudia Kienzler
zur Unternehmerin geworden.
Sie trägt die Verantwortung
für drei Angestellte.
Im Atelier
brütet die 39-Jährige über Budgets
und versucht, Geld für ihr
Kulturprojekt aufzutreiben.
Gott sei Dank haben wir dieses Jahr
noch keine Tournee geplant.
Als neues Unternehmen
hätten wir das nicht verkraftet.
Ich begeistert
über die Rückmeldung der Stiftungen.
Ich konnte noch nie ein so
erfolgreiches Fundraising betreiben.
So konnte ich rund die Hälfte der
Kosten der Investitionsleistungen
bis jetzt decken.
Und doch fehlen für den
Betriebsaufbau knapp 200'000 Fr.
Einnahmen durch Veranstaltungen
sind keine in Sicht
und mit Konzerten kann Claudia
momentan kein Geld verdienen.
Es ist mehr meine Überzeugung,
die mich daran hindert,
zu früh bei einer Nothilfe
anzuklopfen.
Auch wenn ich mit meinem Job, meiner
Situation Anspruch darauf habe
oder das beanspruchen könnte.
Ein Teilzeitjob als Dozentin
an der Musikhochschule Luzern
hilft Claudia,
finanziell über die Runden zu kommen.
Während des Shutdown
war nur Online-Unterricht möglich,
jetzt trifft sich die Klasse zum
Didaktikunterricht wieder physisch.
Es braucht eine lange Hand
für den Bogenwechsel.
Was sind die Mittel, damit
der Bogenwechsel schön gelingt?
Also, die Zeit gehört euch.
Ja, mit dem Instrument ...
Ihr könnt darüber sprechen.
Ihr habt 10 Min. Zeit.
Also, Schwerpunkt: motorisches Ziel.
An der Spitze
ist es einfacher, oder?
Das ist eine Art, wie du es für
die Kinder veranschaulichen kannst.
Oder das vielleicht
auch gleich nachspielen.
Der Bogen muss
vor dem Wechsel langsamer werden.
Einen toten Moment haben,
damit du wieder wenden kannst.
Es hat etwas Befreiendes,
wieder einmal
physischen Unterricht zu haben,
weil er sehr praxisorientiert ist.
Zusammen schauen, entwickeln ist
über Zoom einfach extrem schwierig.
So, wollt ihr der Klasse mitteilen,
was eure Ergebnisse sind?
Wir haben herausgefunden,
dass die meiste Arbeit
mit dem kleinen Finger geschieht.
Und dass es auch wichtig ist,
dass er auf der Stange bleibt.
Dann eben praktische Übungen.
Nur mit den Fingern probieren ...
Es ist ein bisschen schade,
dass das jetzt,
wo wir uns
wieder sehen können,
der letzte Unterricht
vor den Ferien.
Wie ist es für euch?
Ich finde es gut, dass man
gerade in der Fachdidaktik
die Sachen
wieder zusammen anschauen kann.
Es ist halt schwieriger
über Videochats.
Tschüss, danke.
Also abgesehen davon,
dass ich den Job extrem gerne mache,
mit den Studierenden arbeiten,
interaktiver Unterricht
und die Form
des interaktiven Unterrichts,
bin ich froh darum,
etwas gehabt zu haben
oder immer noch etwas
in dieser verdienstlosen Zeit
als Musikerinnen und Musiker
zu haben.
Etwas, das weiterläuft.
Das gibt mir
die monatliche Absicherung
für den grossen Teil
meiner Fixkosten, die weiterlaufen.
Eine beruhigende Tatsache.
Denn nach wie vor sind alle Konzerte
wegen Corona gestrichen.
In Willisau scheint es bei der
Hunziker AG ein guter Tag zu werden.
Roland Küng
erwartet seine Berufskollegen,
um einen Verband zu gründen.
Und dann gibt es auch noch
positive News vom Bundesrat:
Ah, jetzt die Bundesrats-PK.
Die Abstandsregel
geht auf 1,5 m runter,
die Polizeistunde wird aufgehoben.
Das ist auch sehr wichtig.
Die Veranstaltungen bis 1'000 Per-
sonen sind ab Montag wieder erlaubt.
Super.
Das gibt Hoffnung.
Unsere grossen Anlässe,
die abgesagt sind, bleiben abgesagt.
Es gibt Hoffnung, es kommt wieder
etwas rein. Das berührt mich.
Und das nach vier Monaten. Jetzt
habe ich wieder ein wenig Hoffnung.
Jetzt warte ich auf die Kollegen.
Die freuen sich sicher auch.
Die Geschäftsführer von vier
Festzeltbauer-Firmen treffen ein.
Hoi zäme!
Marc, Markus.
Michi. Hoi, Dani.
Wie geht es euch?
Jetzt läuft eine Medieninfo.
Ich habe sie eben auf dem Handy
gehört. Bis 1'000 ist erlaubt.
Bis 1'000?
- Ja, ab Montag.
Und bei dir?
Nichts, praktisch nichts.
Ist es bei euch anders? Kaum.
Doch, wir konnten auf dem
Waffenplatz Thun etwas aufstellen.
Von daher ist es positiv,
aber es ist ein Tropfen
auf den heissen Stein.
Wir mussten vor drei Wochen
Leute entlassen.
Drei Personen.
Das war schon sehr, sehr emotional.
Z.T. waren es
langjährige Mitarbeiter.
Das geht einem
definitiv unter die Haut.
Man muss das auch bis im April
nächsten Jahres durchstehen können.
Mit einem Verband
wollen die Branchenkollegen
auf ihre schwierige Lage
aufmerksam machen.
Aus Konkurrenten werden Verbündete.
Es gibt Themen, die kann
eine Firma alleine nicht stemmen.
Wir haben
über Arbeitssicherheit gesprochen,
über Generalarbeitsverträge,
damit die Spiesse
auch gleich lang sind.
Eine Professionalisierung
der Branche geht nur,
wenn wir eure Stimme haben.
Ich nenne das manchmal
Elefantentreffen, überspitzt gesagt.
Ein paar Grössere der Branche
treffen sich und tauschen sich aus,
im positiven Sinn.
Man spürt einander.
Gut, dann stimmen wir
über die Statuten,
so wie sie jetzt sind
mit allen Änderungen, ab.
Wer den Statuten zustimmt,
soll bitte die Hand erheben.
Danke. Für den Protokollführer:
Das ist einstimmig.
Verband Tectum gegründet, dafür
müssen wir uns fast applaudieren.
Doch schon in der nächsten Folge
wächst die Verzweiflung
bei Roland Küng:
Müssen wir nun noch
zusätzliche Massnahmen ergreifen?
Ich spreche es an: Personalkosten.
Senkung, sprich Entlassungen.
Auch die Musikerin Claudia Kienzler
spürt die Folgen der Krise:
Bis im September ist alles abgesagt.
Bis im September?
- Jawohl, auch das KKL.
Das sind über 1'000 Leute.
Und die Betreiber des Hotel Beau
Séjour bangen um die Sommersaison.
Ohne Ausländer überleben wir nicht.
Das geht allen so,
und das geht sehr schnell.
Man muss geöffnet haben,
sonst geht es bergab.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Liz Lei - 2021